- So hi Dallas!
- Hi there!
- Hi! We've given you a lollipop too.
- I have it here yes. It doesn't look
very appetizing I' ve got to say.
-Yes I think Zara feels the same here as well.
Now, okay, I want you both to place your
tongue between the prongs here. Okay?
-Really?
-Yes now of course like I said you don't
do this at home this is being specially
designed for this.
Okay are you ready?
You take it off me. Okay?
-Zara you go first I'm gonna wait to see what happens
Okay you ready Dallas?
-Okay
-Now you should be able to taste the flavour.
Just put it on your tongue.
- Oh God that is strong! Wow! Oh!
-Is it strong?
-Oh it tastes sour, yeah.
-You get sour as well?
- Mhm
- Is it very sour?
- Yeah it's quite sour.
- So what's happening is that device is sending small
electric currents through those prongs.
So it's stimulating the taste buds on the tongue.
So by varying that current we can vary
which of the taste buds are being
stimulated and what flavour they can
taste as well.
What do you both think of
that experience?
- I don't think the inventors are gonna win MasterChef just yet but I think it's a really interesting technology.
- Well they might not be winning it
because it's well known that we rely
heavily on our smells to help us
distinguish between tastes. So we have
another device for you to try.
Are you ready for this Zara?
There is a device called a "Scentee" which attaches to your smartphone just using the headphone jack here.
So the idea is people can send you
smells over the Internet.
[LAUGHTER]
Now I know what you're thinking. Do I
really want to be able to smell my friends?
Probably not. Well it's okay for
the moment because we don't have that
many smells, we only have a choice of ten
so you're gonna have no nasty surprises.
Okay.
Now Dallas you should have one as well.
- I've got mine here yeah.
- Okay so what we're going to do is
I'm going to try releasing a lemon smell
to you as you have the lemon taste on
your tongue. Okay?
And this is really cool, we need to see this coming out here.
Are we ready?
Okay let's try this! Lollipops at the
ready and...
Sniff.
Can you sniff it?
Yeah? Can you smell that?
- Yeah.
- What does that smell like now then?
- It makes it more like lemony.
- It does make it more lemony yeah. Do you get that sort
of lemon sherbet sort of taste?
- Oh wow, wow!
- Dallas, what do you think?
- I think it's amazing you get proper little jets of scent and yeah it is very sherbety but
it also makes the taste a lot more vivid I suppose if
that's the right word, a lot more obvious.
- Does it feel more real when you have the
taste and the smell there?
- Yeah I think it's more sharp.
- Yes it's more sour isn't it when it's just the lemons
where now it it's a bit more like a
lemon cake or lemon sherbet isn't it?
- I think sherbet is exactly the right word
because this actually gives you that
almost that kind of fizzing
sensation on your tongue.
- Brilliant!
Okay, well thank you very much I hope you
enjoyed sharing a meal together.
A feast of lemons! Thank you very much!
[APPLAUSE]